hello everybody welcome to my raspberry
PI's tutorial on the tutorial we're
going to be talking about everything
raspberry pi but initially just the
basic setting up of raspberry pi you
look around a line I assume a lot of you
guys prior watching this before you even
have a raspberry pi but if you look
around a line it looks like ooh man that
might be kind of difficult to setup a
raspberry pi I don't really know what
I'm doing but it's actually very very
easy so initially when you finally buy a
raspberry pi it's been your little joys
going to come in this box and within the
box will just be the board that contains
the raspberry pi so let me set the
camera down here and when you open it up
this is all it's in there basically and
we'll just go ahead and take her out so
this is what you get with your Raspberry
Pi
you've got audio RCA you've got some IO
here we'll be talking a lot about this
one and but if you've got the ethernet
one that has Ethernet you'll have an
Ethernet spot there for a cat5 cable
we're hearing that your HDMI which is
nice you've got a couple USB obviously
you can slap it in a USB extender there
and finally you have a lawyer power spot
basically and that power is even though
a lot of people try to sell you up how
like Raspberry Pi power cables really
all you need is a cell phone charger
okay and you want to have some it's put
any pushing 5 volts at preferably over a
thousand plus milliamp but it can be
anything as low as seven hundred
millions so just find something that
does that basically a cell phone charger
that's what's going to do it seven 100
billion is more than fine if you're
running it headless but if you're
connecting monitor you've got some
Ethernet coming in and out and you bet
some USB mouse and keyboard being pushed
out of this thing you're going to need
more likely around a thousand
milliamps or more just so it's stable
that way like heads and flows aren't
going to shut the thing down so the last
thing you want to do is have this thing
turn off on you it's really unstable as
far as the SD card is concerned
I've already had my SD card has been
corrupted like three times what's they
do to overclocking anyway so that's that
you're also gonna obviously want
something you don't have to buy one
specifically for the board right the
least in the initial setup you're going
to want to have a monitor keyboard um I
just a monitoring keyboard is probably
the best thing to have immediately you
could have a mouse just to make it a
little easier but for the most part
monitor keyboard and an SD card usually
it's not going to come with any of those
things because they just kind of assume
that everybody has monitor an SD card
cell phone with charger so yeah you just
need one of those little micro USB
things to charge it really just plug it
in there's no on/off switch so if it's
plugged in it's on and then the other
thing I would just recommend is you get
one of these old cases I'll show you
guys with it indication a bit but this
is kind of what it looks like you just
kind of piece the case together um I see
this one a lot everywhere I'm actually
really happy with it the fit is like
perfect and I think it looks ok I like
that it's clear I like to look at the
board but there's tons of cases I highly
suggest you get one otherwise dust will
fall in here and the last thing you want
is eventually dust to cover over this
lowly TB baby processor here basically
is that it's going to insulate a lot of
heat so anyway that's how with the
basics next I'm going to be showing you
guys is how to prepare your SD card to
put on the operating system and I set
that up and then base and then
eventually we'll get this bad boy turned
on I'll show you guys how easy it is to
get everything set up and at least get
to a desktop that's what everybody you
know you're familiar with seeing a
desktop so we will be getting to that
point and have no fear it's very simple
so as always thank you for watching
thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time